la morgan avec le calendrier alors est
ce que j'ai à faire le 12 mai alors moi
qui adore les chevaux j'adore celle là
je suis à l'équitation à cheval même un
poney je suis comme un fou c'est à dire
agir connaît là ces flibustiers sa
cinquième gp dans la deuxième le
calendrier de clara morgane
ça rigolait tu l'attends c'est comme
quand tu attends le pied de le ton petit
navire on dirait qu'ils arrivent en
bateau était au port comme ça et quand
il fait le calendrier comme rien n'est
sûr
c'est quoi ça c'est quoi ça m et ça doit
être très dur de se mettre comme ça sur
un s'était pas oui c'est d'être de tout
repos baillif du chemin c'est un cheval
mais ça c'est alors ça c'est du passé et
du présent
c'est mon vrai stock de bois en fait nos
ruminer ce que c'est chez moi et ce en
provence et comme on était confiné à
l'époque du suicide
on a eu envie mais on se voit pas là
sinon je compte bien dotées dé l'atlas
est bon je refasse un brainstorming tous
les mardis à voir exactement toute la
rédac
ok les gars alors ça ça c'est magnifique
ça c'était ça s'était passé au bois de
même sur un voyage d'accord la balle est
donc sebha au sud de la france et moi je
vous dis bonjour voyage à voies larges
et la magnifique
est-ce qu'on peut mettre le mois de
doutes alors pour les amateurs de cactus
de toi c'est pas une légende
c'est chez vous aussi c'est moi on peut
voir septembre la rentrée avec plaisir
ces deux fautes lampre la rentrée des
classes
merci ya quand même un gant régis
descott club l'a alors ah bah septembre
j'aurais séchage alors moi mon
anniversaire c'est le 23 septembre
c'est juste là entre la toile à l'issue
de ce sommet de la miss la somed
attriste à 23 septembre elle nous
d'aller n'est justement pas voilà ça
c'est fait à octobre alors octobre avec
clara alors suivre ah oui c'est beau
c'est du chêne
[Rires]
je suis fan de call of scotland s'est
toujours classée toujours classé non
mais c'est vrai mais c'est ce que
j'essaie vraiment de faire saisir que je
peins je suis une femme j'aime pas la
vulgarité j'essaie toujours de faire des
choses et les gants de trouver des idées
originales pour ben wallace et on a eu
la chance d'avoir ces magnifiques
c'était un cheval
voilà c'était lui exactement les bannis
en tout cas si tu veux des cours
d'équitation n'hésite pas elle moi quand
tu veux d'accord le calendrier clara il
n'est pas une faveur nouveau le mois
d'août vendredi très bien le vendredi 13
au mois d'août
oui on peut vérifier quand on doit
vérifier d'un droit des treize mois
d'août
oui c'est on n'a pas le monde sait bien
ouah ça va c'est le vendredi 3 bis est
alors pour ce juste pour vérifier un
petit peu vite
[Rires]